des voix discordantes autour du vaccin
astrazeneca lui même concerné olivier
ferrand l'a annoncé ce vendredi
les personnes ayant reçu leur première
injection du vaccin suédo britanniques
pourront recevoir leur deuxième dose
d'un autre vaccin à arn
il est tout à fait cohérent de dire on
ne recommande pas le vaccin astrazeneca
au moins de 55 ans en attendant d'en
savoir plus
et donc si vous allez reçu une première
injection et que vous avez moins de 55
ans on va vous proposer un autre vaccin
à 12 semaines après la première
injection vous recevrez une injection
d'un vaccin arn messager un avis que
rejoint également la haute autorité de
santé qui jugent cette pratique
fréquente dans la lutte d'autres
maladies comme evola ce vendredi
l'institution a confirmé qu utiliser
deux vaccins combinés et largement
préconisé une solution qui concerne plus
de cinq cent mille personnes en france
la décision a finalement été
relativement simple
on sait qu'une seule dose de vaccin
n'est pas suffisante pour assurer une
immunité au long cours contre lakovic 19
il fallait donc prendre une décision sur
le vaccin administré pour la deuxième
dose
il a donc été décidé d'utiliser un
vaccin arn on sait que ça marche très
bien et cela donne des réponses
immunitaires qui sont plus importantes
que lorsqu'on utilise deux fois le même
vaccin mais l'organisation mondiale de
la santé n'est pas du même avis tant que
les données ne sont pas suffisamment
exploitées le changement de vaccins
entre deux doses n'est pas recommandé il
n'y a pas de données adéquates pour dire
si c'est quelque chose qui peut être
fait l'interchangeabilité des vaccins
n'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
recommander à ce stade autorisé le 2
février dernier le vaccin astrazeneca
était dans un premier temps administré
aux plus de 65 ans pour être élargie
ensuite à toute la population
après les décès consécutifs suite à des
cas de thrombose de plusieurs personnes
ayant reçu ce vaccin
il a été momentanément suspendue en
france et dans plusieurs pays d'europe
pour en évaluer les risques en france
depuis le 19 mars dernier
il est uniquement administré aux plus de
55 ans